Hi everyone, this is Steve Gilbert.
Welcome to Lecture 19, where we're going to talk
about arrays and pointers.
Now, an array is like a vector, except it's built in.
So it's a built in derived type.
What do we mean by a derived type?
A derived type is one that is built from another type.
So a pointer is a derived type.
You just can't have a raw pointer that is not of any type.
It has to be a pointer to an integer or a pointer
to a double, and so forth.
And an array is the same way.
We can't just have an array that collects anything.
We have to have an array of int or an array of double.
So it's a built in derived type for collecting elements.
Now, we use the term array in Java as well,
but arrays are quite, quite different in C++.
They are much closer to the actual machine type,
the way that your CPU works and memory works under the hood.
So like the vector, they're a homogeneous collection.
All of them has to be the same type.
And like a vector, we have continuous storage,
contiguous storage, meaning one element right next
to each other, and random access,
direct access to any element.
So let's see how we define an array.
So to define an array, we give the base type double,
the name of the array, and then in brackets afterwards,
the number of elements inside the array.
So unlike Java, where you could create an array variable,
double nums bracket bracket or double bracket bracket nums,
you cannot create an array variable
without specifying how many elements you want.
And that capacity must be a constant,
and it must be known at compile time.
Again, this is different than Java.
In Java, you could ask the user how big an array,
and then you could create a new array with that size.
You can't create a regular, what we call a static array,
that way in C++.
Now, this array definition will allocate an entire block.
So int a5, if we put that line inside a function,
will allocate a block of five integers on the heap.
There is no separate variable that points to this.
The address is simply, the name a is simply the address
of the first element.
There's no additional, what we would call,
metadata associated with it.
Now, the access is sequential.
One right on top of another on the stack, and contiguous.
So we can simply go from one to another,
simply by using addresses.
So if we want the element at 795,
we just take the address a,
and add 795 times the size of whatever the element is.
So the size of int, in this case.
And that gives us the address.
So it's simple, simple arithmetic.
It's very, very fast.
And as a matter of fact, it's even faster than it looks like,
because your CPU has dedicated address circuits that know how
to do these calculations without having to go
through the regular addition
and multiplication part of the CPU.
So there is really no faster way to store data in memory
at all than built-in arrays.
Now, arrays can be initialized in all versions of C++.
And so I can allocate space for four elements,
and I can supply values for all four of them.
Now, notice this is slightly different than what we did
with vectors, because with vectors,
we didn't use the equal sign here.
The equal sign's required as part of the syntax.
So I've allocated and initialized four elements.
I can allocate more and only initialize one,
in which case the remaining elements will be initialized
to zero as well.
Now, not because I put zero inside here.
If I had to put four, the first element would be initialized
to four, and the remaining elements would be initialized
to zero.
What happens if I do this?
Allocate room for three and provide four initializers.
Well, C++ won't let you do that,
and it simply doesn't compile.
How about if I don't allocate any space?
I just leave that blank.
That's fine as well.
C++ will come along, and it will count the number of elements,
and it will implicitly fill this three in for you.
Now, there's one new thing in C++11.
So all versions of C++ work like this.
In C++11, you can simply default initialize it just
by putting braces after it.
If you do not initialize it, the elements are just random.
Now, the individual elements are indexed or subscripted,
just like they would in a vector,
and you access them using the subscript operator.
So A and then the subscript.
That subscript can go from zero to whatever the capacity
of the array is minus one.
So if A has four elements, the elements would be zero, one,
two, three, capacity is five.
What happens with an array if we go out of bounds?
We saw with the vector that it was undefined
if we use the subscript operator,
but we could use V.at three,
and we could throw an exception if that happens.
There's no thing like that for arrays.
If you go out of bounds, you simply get undefined behavior.
The program may crash.
It may access parts of memory it should not.
It may overwrite other variables inside your program.
So you don't know what it's going to do.
What you do know is that it is never an exception.
It is never an exception.
C++ does not throw exceptions for out of bounds.
You may get a segmentation fault, as I said,
if the area you're reading and writing to is outside the
segment that the operating system allows you to write to,
or you may simply overwrite other variables
in your own program.
Now, there's no array variable like there is in Java.
So this is what an array would look like in Java.
We create an array variable, and then we'd create
or allocate room for 10 arrays, or 10 ints.
The 10 ints would be on the heap.
That would be the array,
and the variable would be separate from the array.
That doesn't happen in Java.
There's not these two parts with a variable and an array.
Instead, or that doesn't happen in C++.
Excuse me.
Instead, in C++, the array name acts
like a constant pointer or literal.
Because of that, because there is no array variable,
you can't assign or compare using array names.
So here I have two arrays.
A1 has three elements.
It's initialized, 2, 3, 4.
A2 also has three elements of the same type,
but they're uninitialized.
Could I initialize A2 by simply assigning A1?
No, you cannot.
A2 and A1 are addresses.
Imagine it's address 1,000 and 2,000.
That's like writing 2,000 equals 1,000.
Again, in your code, you can see why that wouldn't compile.
It is okay, of course, to assign
to different arrays using the elements
or the subscripted name.
So we could say A2 sub 0 equals A1 sub 0.
And you could write a loop that would go through
and assign each of those.
You might think, well, you notice on the first line there,
I could assign to A1 using these braces,
what we call an initializer list.
Can I do that to assign to A2?
No. You can only do that when you're initializing the thing.
You cannot use it for assignment later.
That simply doesn't work.
Finally, you can do this.
If A2 equals equals A3, okay, well,
actually I don't have an A3 here.
It probably should say if A1 equals equals A2.
But both of those would be perfectly legal.
They will compile, but they are really not very smart.
That's because, again, A1 and A2 are different arrays.
That means all A1 and A2 are are addresses.
So we're not comparing what's at those addresses to see
if they're the same.
We're comparing the addresses themselves.
So address 1000 is never, never,
ever going to be equal to address 2000.
By definition, that's false.
So the compiler can't check things
that simply don't make sense that way.
It can only check things that are illegal.
Now, the array does not carry around its size like a vector.
As I mentioned, there is no metadata associated
with an array like there is with a vector.
There is no A dot length data member or field
as there is with Java arrays.
Now, the compiler knows the size of an array
when it's declared, however.
And so if you're in scope of that declaration,
the compiler knows that information.
So I can find out in scope, here I've created an array A,
I can find the size of this declaration in bytes if I'm
in the scope of this declaration.
And if I want to find the number of elements,
all I do is divide the size of the whole array by the size
of the first element.
And since they're all the same size by definition,
this will give me the number of elements in the array.
But again, only in scope.
C++11 added a new way to do that.
We can take the array and pass it to end and subtract begin
from it, and that will give us the number of elements.
And finally, in C++14,
they had a new function simply called size
that will also work on arrays.
So you could pass A to standard size,
and you could get back the number of elements in the array.
Again, I want to stress this, this only works
when the array is in scope,
not when you've passed the array to a function.
All right.
So how -- if we have an array, it doesn't have any metadata,
it doesn't know how long the function is,
it doesn't have a size member function,
it doesn't have a length data member, how does the loop know
how to stop in your function if when you pass the array
to a function, the only thing the function gets is the address
of the first element?
Well, number first method, we could pass the allocated
or maximum size along with the address.
Method two, we could use a sentinel
to mark the end of the array.
Number three, we could calculate a pointer to the end,
and we could pass that pointer to the end as well
and write an iterator loop.
We could pass -- use the begin and end iterators
and pass those instead of the address of the first element.
Or finally, inside the scope of the array
where it's declared, we can use a for each loop.
So we're going to do that in our only exercise today.
We're going to create some arrays, and we're going
to loop through them.
So go ahead and open arrays.cpp in your workspace,
and then let's create five arrays.
A three-element int, a four-element char,
a five-element long, a six-element float,
and a seven-element double.
Okay. So I've got arrays.cpp open over here,
and I want to create my arrays.
So I can -- first for my three-element int,
I could do const int iSize -- I'll do it like this --
k iSize equals three.
And then I could do int integer array IA equals kSize.
Now, what would happen -- what would happen if I were
to take off this const in front of this, if I were to take off
that const in front of it?
First, let's do make on this.
Let me make my shell so I'm over in that folder, of course.
Okay. So I'm in A, and that's k iSize.
So that was giving me an error because I had spelled that wrong.
So make, and I don't have any problems with that at all.
Okay. Now I'm going to remove the int from this,
const from that, and try it again.
And you will probably find that it will compile.
Okay. That's because most --
and if we were doing this in Visual Studio,
it would not compile.
Visual Studio would be correct in that case.
What I can do over here is open up my make file
and add an extra flag on the flags, and say I want
to make this pedantic, and that will ensure
that it only uses the C++ standard.
Now when I do make, notice it says ISO C++ forbids an area --
a variable length array IA.
So this needs to be const to be correct,
even if in some compilers you can get away with it.
In some compilers you can get away with it.
But since it's not really correct according
to the language, you shouldn't do it.
So we could create an array like this.
This is uninitialized.
So let's create an array with four chars.
So char CA, and put the brackets there
and initialize it like this.
Brace brace semicolon.
C -- hold on, I'm having a hard time getting my fingers
on the right keys here.
A P -- and I'm going to put a terminator in here, a sentinel,
that we're going to look for when we process
that array, okay?
A sentinel, okay?
And notice this time I didn't initialize it.
We're going to create a five element long.
So char LA.
You can put in a literal like that.
And for our LA we'll do it 10, 20, 30.
And we'll find out that there won't be a 40 or 50,
it'll just be zeros and zeros for that last one.
A six element float.
[ Typing ]
Okay, now you might notice
that these are not floats inside of here, these are doubles.
But because this is initialization,
this will require a conversion to convert it
down to the floats.
If you didn't want that conversion,
we could make each one a float.
[ Typing ]
Like that.
That's always a better thing, you know,
to say in your code exactly what you're trying to do.
Okay, and finally we had our double, double DA.
And I'm going to use C++11.
And just default initialize everything to zero, okay?
Everything to zero.
All right, let's do make here again on this.
And now it compiles without errors.
So that's initializing and creating five arrays.
Now we're going to print each array using the array name
and see what happens.
So this is one print using the array name.
So I'm going to C out.
I'm going to print the array name as well.
So I'm going to print IA equals IA.
CA equals CA.
C out. LA. Oops.
LA equals LA.
C out. FA equals FA.
And C out.
DA.
DA didn't turn blue.
Oh, there it turned blue.
Okay. So let's go ahead and do make run.
Nothing ran.
Oh, I didn't.
No. Let me save it and do make once again.
Okay. I'm going to pause this while I figure
out what's going on right now.
Because that doesn't make any sense at all.
Oh, no. I don't need to pause it.
I just need to look and that my return zero is
up there before my print.
Which is a bad thing.
Okay. So let's do make run.
Okay. So IA prints out.
IA is simply the address for where I starts.
CA doesn't print out the address where the C starts.
It prints out cat.
LA. So I apparently made a mistake here.
LA prints that.
FA doesn't appear to be -- oh, no.
There's FA.
LA prints there and then seems to print a new line at the end.
I'm not quite sure why.
What did we do with LA?
LA we initialized to three elements, right?
And it's five long.
So I'm not sure why LA is not printing -- oh, you know.
I made LA a char.
I'm supposed to make it a long.
So again, user error here.
User error here.
Okay. Make run.
Okay. So IA, LA, FA, DA, all of those print the address
of the first element of the array.
CA does not.
So to explain why CA does not, look at this piece of code.
Okay? What is this quote?
Is that a string object?
No, it is not a string object.
It is an array of characters terminated with a null,
what we call a C string.
And so C out has an overloaded operator that looks like this
or string has an overloaded operator that looks like this.
O stream ref operator.
O stream ref out const char star S or CS for C string.
Okay? So when we pass CA here,
what we're doing is we're passing a pointer
to a constant character or a pointer to a char.
And so it's treating it exactly the same way it treats this.
So for all arrays, we will get the address IA, LA, FA, and DA.
But for character arrays, we will actually get the sequence
of characters that's inside it.
What do I do if I want to find out where the address
where CA is?
What I can do is I can cast this, so static cast void pointer.
In other words, a raw pointer to nothing, CA.
And now if I run that, make run, notice we'll get the addresses
where each of these items are stored in memory.
These are all stored in the stack because they're
in the local storage.
If I had created all of these outside of this function,
this global variables, they would be
in the static storage area.
All right.
So we've created them.
We've seen that the name of the array is just an address.
Now let's print the contents of each array.
And I'm going to use five different loops,
the five different loops we had on the previous slide.
Okay? So let's start.
Print the arrays, array contents.
And let's start is a traditional loop with size.
So I'm going to print IA.
We have a constant for IA.
So I'm going to say for I equals zero, IIA less than KI size,
plus plus I.
C out IA. Let me go there.
IA at I. And let me just do space.
And let me print.
[ Typing ]
Okay. So let's print.
Let's do that first one, make run.
And here's our first array.
You can see I have three elements.
They're uninitialized.
So they're just random values.
Now notice I didn't use the fence post algorithm here.
I used an algorithm where we have a space before
and after each element here.
And so I didn't need to print the first one separately.
I used this fence post for the next ones.
So now we're going to do 2B, use a sentinel.
Of course, you saw we could just print out the string.
But I want to show you how a sentinel works.
So here I'll use a sentinel.
So I'll say C out CA equals.
I use square brackets.
[ Typing ]
I'll say for.
And here we're going to say CA at I not equal
to the null character.
So you notice I'm not using size for my bounds at all.
I'm using the sentinel in there.
[ Typing ]
I want actually a space between each one.
And we'll print that.
[ Typing ]
And C out.
Okay. So here's CA using a sentinel loop.
Let me clear that.
Demake run.
So here's CAT.
Notice we didn't take the length
into consideration at all with CA.
We just took into consideration the fact
that it contained a terminating character.
A sentinel character.
Okay. All right.
Our third kind of loop.
Third kind of loop is calculate a pointer to the end.
Okay. And then we're going to use that.
[ Typing ]
To see.
And we're going to calculate a pointer to the end
with the size of it.
So this is going to be -- our third one is going
to be LA and it's five long.
[ Typing ]
And so we're going to --
LA equals the opening bracket.
And let's actually on this one since I know --
[ Typing ]
We print the first one up there.
Okay. Now we don't want to go to the size.
What we want to do is say for I equals zero, LA plus I.
So actually let's create the pointer to it
because when we're calling a function we would pass this
pointer to it.
So I'll say auto end P equals LA plus the size
of LA divided by the size of LA sub zero.
Okay. So I've calculated a pointer to the end.
Okay. I'm going to use a pointer to the beginning.
[ Typing ]
For a long pointer P equals LA, P less than end P, P plus plus.
LA plus one.
[ Typing ]
Oh, not an end.
Okay. Not an end.
Okay. So here we're just using pointers, right,
a pointer to the beginning and a pointer to the end.
And we calculate that pointer to the end
by taking the size of LA, its allocated size,
divided by the size of the first element
which gives us the number of elements.
This will give us a pointer right past the end.
And we'll see how square bracket ends up.
Okay. Let's try that third one.
I have end there instead of P end or end P.
[ Typing ]
Okay. And then we got our 10, 20, 30.
And as I mentioned, we only initialized the first three
so the last two are initialized to zero.
Unlike this one up here where everything is uninitialized.
Everything is uninitialized.
Okay. Okay.
So that was 2C for 2D.
[ Typing ]
We can just use iterators.
Let's see how FA.
[ Typing ]
And we'll do star, begin, FA.
Print out the first element.
[ Typing ]
For auto iter equals begin FA plus 1.
Iter not equal to end FA plus plus iter.
[ Typing ]
And for 2E.
Now all of these will work inside a function
if you pass the arguments.
If you pass up here the size as an argument.
This you don't need to pass anything.
If it's got a terminator in it, you're fine.
A sentinel in it.
This you would have to pass this second argument, the end pointer.
This you'd have to pass both begin and end to the function
to do your calculation.
And for this one, only works inside a loop.
This one would not work inside a function.
So this is the range for loop.
Okay.
[ Typing ]
So this is a little harder.
If we want to do -- this is going to be DA equals square bracket.
And we're going to do DA sub zero.
We're going -- so this one with a range for loop,
it's kind of hard to do the fence post algorithm.
And so we're going to have to create a Boolean.
[ Typing ]
We're going to have to go for auto E and DA.
If printing C out comma E. And then that will skip the first one.
We'll turn on the printing for the second one.
Okay. So a little hard to do fence post with the range base loop
because it goes through every element in the array.
Okay. So that's it.
Let's go ahead and try these out.
Do make run.
And here's our last one.
This one, remember, we initialized all to zeros like that.
All to zeros like that.
Okay. We're going to do one more thing here.
[ Typing ]
And that is I'm going to try and read and write outside
of the array bounds before printing.
And we want to see what happens to the other arrays.
So this, like I said, it's undefined.
You're not sure exactly what's going to happen.
But I want to show you
that the compiler won't stop us from doing this.
So let's come up here.
After we've printed out those names.
It's going to be part three.
[ Typing ]
So let's say FA sub minus 2 equals 3.
And let's say LA.
How big was LA?
LA was 5.
LA sub 7 equals 15.
Okay. So 3 and 15.
Now let's run it again.
I want you to see what it looked like before.
So here's what it looked like before.
We'll do make run.
[ Typing ]
And now look down here at DA.
At DA. And notice that we have this value put inside here.
So by changing FA, we actually changed DA.
Now it doesn't look like the one we did
in LA actually overwrote any other variables.
But it could have.
We could have kept going and changed.
We were writing at LA 7.
Let's write it LA 9.
Let's try it again and see if the LA changes anything.
So we'll do make run again.
And okay.
So this looking at LA, that looks like that's the LA is the
one I'm changing.
Looks like the FA, I didn't actually affect any
of the other variables.
So we'd have to look at these addresses.
We'd have to draw ourselves a little memory map.
And we'd be able to tell what happens
when we write outside of that.
But you notice it didn't give me a syntax error.
It didn't give me a compiler error.
It simply overwrote parts of my other program.
Those are very, very hard bugs to find.
Okay. So that's it for Lecture 19.
When you come on back for Lecture 20,
we'll look at some algorithms for arrays.